look mitch mcconnell's a disaster the
republicans have to get a new leader
mitch mcconnell allowed this to happen
the infrastructure bill i call it
infrastructure not infrastructure it's
only nine percent infrastructure so that
means you take 90 percent 91 of the
money that we're raising is going to be
thrown out the window in order to get
nine percent infrastructure
there was no way that that should have
been passed should have been a hundred
percent for infrastructure so what's
happening is
we had a thing called the debt ceiling
and he could have used that to win
everything and he chose not to and we
have a bigger problem because they have
a so-called voting rights bill which is
a voting rights for democrats because
republicans will never be elected again
if that happens if that passes let me
ask you about all of these people that
you've been supporting recently we're
entering the election year the primaries
in march
you've already endorsed several
candidates for re-election what are you
looking for let's go through some of
these contests that are toss up senator
mark kelly in arizona senator raphael
warnock georgia catherine cortez-mastro
nevada maggie hassan new hampshire what
are you what are your they're a disaster
they're for open borders therefore
defunding the police they're for crime
in other words they're for crime they're
for taking away your second amendment
so they want to take away your police
and then take away your right to protect
yourself when you think of it right
these people are a disaster and they
should all lose and we have some great
candidates and sometimes i'm going a
little outside of the box with some
because we have candidates that are not
strong they're rhinos and they're not
strong they're mitch mcconnell type guys
and he's a disaster so we need tougher
people we need people that are going to
be able to win for our country not win
for me by the way win for our country
and we have some great candidates the
other day hillary clinton said that if
you win again it is the end of democracy
will this be a rematch
oh i have no idea i hope so i mean i'd
like that but but look the woman's
crooked as can be
she cheated on the election they spied
on my campaign
remember i put out that little statement
they're spying on my campaign and all
hell broke out you know why it broke out
because they knew i was right they knew
i was right and all of these things that
happened and we caught them let's see
what happens now let's see what happens
to hunter let's see what happens to all
of it just today he called kamala harris
president again
do you think someone else is
directing him well i never called mike
pence president i'll tell you i can't
imagine
what's going on it's hard to believe
who's writing the contract well think of
it
it was so obvious in this case because
450 000 he was incensed he was very
upset by that question
asked by a very good reporter actually
but he was very angry at that question
like
how dare you what a stupid question of
course the next morning he was saying
how yeah this is something that we think
is excellent
that really means in the truest sense
that he is not running the country
because there's no way you go from
indignation to oh that's wonderful
and i hope you had a good interview what
do you think the strategy is around the
border two million people apprehended
this year six hundred thousand others
getting away the amount of illicit
narcotics coming in is incredible
fentanyl we had one hundred thousand
overdoses just in the last year largely
due to fentanyl hundreds of thousands a
hundred thousand but hundreds of
thousands of people are dying you know
if this were a war
and if we lost two three hundred
thousand i think that's the real number
with drugs and much of it's coming
through
the southern border there's never been a
war that anybody lost numbers like this
we're losing
hundreds of thousands of people a year
to drugs we had it at a level that they
haven't seen in years because they
couldn't get in and when when we have an
open border we're not just talking about
the people as we said we're talking
about the drugs that are coming in the
human trafficking mostly in women they
traffic in women children to a much
lesser extent but they trap they traffic
in women and what they do they'll put
six women in the trunk of a car i mean
what they do these are animals and
we had it really largely stopped it
would have been just about stopped and
then these people got into office and
they've destroyed it they're destroying
our
country coming